hey BuzzFeed I'm Sophia Bush and I'm
here to talk about my first time that
sound like something first of all that
comes to mind you think of your one true
character Davis oh there's so many gems
I loved
ciao [ __ ] I loved her epic empowering
speech on the warrior she's got a real
real good ones hi friend
I gave her that one and it was pervasive
through the show thank you very much and
also a writer I bet you didn't know
first fashion trend erupted in the early
2000 never want to see me come back home
there were many wrong things many red
carpet my first cell phone oh whatever
that first Nokia phone was with
interchangeable tops so you could like
match your phone to your outfit again
many thanks first memory from the set of
One Tree Hill the first thing that came
to mind is in the memory of the SEC it's
a memory of going to this awesome
rooftop bar in restaurant early and it
was the first week that we were there
and we decided to go out and hang and we
went to this bar and we both believe in
21 for 3 weeks so getting into a bar
legally we felt like a really big deal
and we went up there and be like
ordering a cocktail sat and chatted and
we just felt like ladies it was very
cool so that feels like my first memory
first rule you really wanted to win to
someone else oh my god
I remember in college when we taught it
for this part and this tiny movie maybe
already become catch me if you can with
this guy you know
you may know him and there was a girl
who just loved him in this movie like
he's a con artist so obviously didn't
work out in a movie not really and amy
has got that part but she was so good
and I remember going to see the movie at
being like all right all right there
she's men innocent she's maybe had my
first kiss oh I had a serious crush on
this sweet boy in the fourth grade we
would sit and have lunch together every
day
and I remember at the end of the year we
were moving cities and it was this very
sweet like business stand by me
everyone was had this suite after a
place and I was a bridge and we were
walking and talking and leaned over and
like kind of kissed me on the cheek and
sort of on the mouth and we were in
fourth grade like you know that gets a
person he was very awkward but in a way
I see it for a bird's-eye view like
these two Lukens just being precious on
a bridge in a park anyway first time you
were starstruck I'm starstruck all the
time when I was a kid so my dad until he
retired with a really fantastic fashion
an advertising photographer and he used
to photograph the cast of Beverly Hills
down to a know all the time I had many
tiny Polaroid six five I'm chill about
it
and I remember Shannen Doherty was doing
a campaign for coop roles like tackle
boxes they kept to make a fan they were
amazing I still have my time and I got
to go to the shoot and I met her and I
was just like oh my god Brenda Walsh
she was very nice I was probably a
disaster my first celebrity friend Henry
Winkler is probably the coolest
celebrity I've known it for the longest
because he's my parents friend but that
means he's my friend too so let's go in
the box
first acting credit I think my first
acting credit was a KitKat commercial
they're delicious but after two days of
eating them I don't think
for a decade first career aspiration
when I was really little I wanted to be
a veterinarian that explicitly treated
horses and by middle school I decided I
wanted to be a pediatric cardiovascular
surgeon and I wound up going in Peter
slow so who knows
my first job I've had to buff stalls at
the barn where I took riding lessons as
a kid I had to work for my dad and do
all the jobs no one else wanted even in
the photo studio every summer and I was
a camp counselor but all of those kind
of overlap but yeah the youngest job was
showing for school so say hello first TV
show you've been watched
I don't know what the first is but I
remember when my best friend Jenny and I
discovered her in black Tatiana maslany
paying everyone on One Show pregnant I
lost all control time worth it first
time you were recognized in public first
season of One Tree Hill days but I don't
remember the first time I was recognized
in public I remember the first time that
Paul Johansen who had been recognized as
public many times before thinks he did
but the first time Paul was recognized
as Dan Scott in public a woman's
reaction to seeing him was to grab her
the strap of her purse which was on her
shoulder take it off of your shoulder
and repeatedly hit him with it and
scream you're a bad dad
and we were so shocked by what we were
witnessing and Paul is so funny and he
has a really wicked spicy sense of humor
and he leaned in anyway yeah I am bad
bad baby
and we were like yes it was an amazing
reaction
my first big audition you go into so
many auditions as an actor I couldn't
tell you what my first audition but I do
remember my first audition for one tree
hill feeling important because I'm
going into me all the producers we did
back just after having worked on
nip/tuck with Ryan Murphy amazing he's
gone that's a good song oh my first
back-to-school memory I remember her
going into the second grade and I went
to a school I had to wear uniforms these
plaid jumpers were white shirts
underneath and I remember getting into
my jumper and it felt so big and looking
down at my feet and realizing I was
gonna have to use them to walk into
school and it felt so exciting and
nerve-wracking and maybe a little sad
because summer was over back to school
feels incredibly relevant and important
right now because I get to spend this
time talking to all of you about a
campaign that I really really am
passionate about one of the things that
stands in the way of girls and our
education all over the world is period
poverty and what you may not know is
that one in five girls here in America
this is school because she was in period
property and what that mean is that we
don't have access to the sanitary
products I mean to manager that's
recycling and the idea that 88,000 image
here in my home city of Los Angeles
alone
miss out on school because of your
period is not okay
I'm really excited to be partnering this
back-to-school month with always they
were running a campaign which is hashtag
and very bubbly and you can jump on my
post about it or any of their posts
about it post that hashtag you like that
photo on social media alone we're
working to get to a million people
talking about this for a million
donations to girls in need so thank you
guys for caring thank you for breaking
the taboo thank you for helping and
period poverty
you
[Music]
you